[Music]
and 50/50 split news submitted by tofu
soup a man who won a 80 million dollar
lottery jackpot during his divorce had
to split it with his ex-wife so cool rub
that in their face 180 million [ __ ] you
he probably did it she was like oh you
want what hey lawyer do I get half of
that yeah we won what how do you
assassinate a lawyer and not get in
trouble I know it couldn't tell this
[ __ ] anything during a divorce this is
exactly why I divorced you oh my god
should have held that [ __ ] until it's
already done because he didn't sign and
it's not final every she's entitled to
everything before that what if he's a
complete dick and she's like a victim in
this whole but no but even if it's not
about that he won so it's that let me
hear the article alright so they weren't
married they were married in 2004 and
they have three children so this is dick
and Mary Beth they were separated for
two years at the time that he won a mega
million which was eighty million dollars
in July 2013 but he ended up taking home
thirty eight million eight hundred
thousand blah blah blah the taxes huh
wait so eighty turn at 38 80 turn to 38
38.8 yeah the government is [ __ ] up
that's cozy means it's like you married
the government got to give him half -
you still gotta play with them can you
take the cat the whole cash first and
then say I'll pay you back government
and then you go run away to Costa Rica
that's smart that's smart Oh
can we Google that can we see if that
you can do that because of the fact that
their divorce wasn't final cuz I was
just finalized in 2018 I believe or
maybe this year oh yeah in 2018 so
because of that they her lawyer said
that she's entitled to half of it like
book yes she is cuz I get it
that's [ __ ] up to me it's not a gender
thing because if she bought the long
ticket issue I had the same reaction
because that [ __ ] did nothing
for the for the lotto ticket neither did
you guys with a lotto ticket he just
paid it no he paid it but yeah so his
lawyers saying that he was lucky but it
was his look not marries and that's why
he should be able to and it is
transaction money thought that the
things that are split is the money that
is met generated together correctly
that's what it should be
cuz you still keep your half of what you
have before you got married and the
money that you make after the divorce I
mean even if like you didn't make this
money together you didn't make that but
that's the loophole where I don't think
they finished a divorce settlement
so technically within the two years the
lottery ticket is still part of what
they earned it what you're saying is for
prenups know the fact that she even
hired a lawyer and was like I think I
deserve half of this is why this guy got
a divorce she is a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
hundred percent about going through a
divorce I would just want to like leave
even if she was a millionaire it's like
leave me the [ __ ] alone I don't want to
but you're not petty yeah I mean I pity
in other ways I'm petty where it counts
if this was the guy if she won and this
was a guy that guy would be the tiniest
man alive for doing that he'd be fifty
dollars richer
he'd be a little [ __ ] though does he
give a [ __ ] about your opinion he's 50
minute you represent to him that's true
he by you you know how many people are
affected by the comments gee I could
leave comments on his [ __ ] and he'll be
like crying and he'll give the money
back that's true he'll give it all back
yeah so because of this cuz this court
ruling they so they did award the girl
it's all mark fifteen million dollars it
sucks but dick is planning to murder her
Supreme Court to try to yeah but what
did she spent at all so she doesn't get
paid yet does she I don't know cousin I
was him I was spend at all and then be
like what now [ __ ] or what he can do
you be extra petty
and him and his lawyer can come up with
like an agreement fine every month until
she gets all her money I pay her $100 Oh
can I put all the money in a wood
chipper and then give her all that I
gave her the money oh you can pay a
penny - Oh pennies is dick - yeah
[ __ ] that comes to me in pennies I'm
like [ __ ] just bank you handle they
just put that [ __ ] in my account
that's what Samsung damn I can't I can't
hurt this [ __ ] listen finish it yeah
baby that bull in pennies or something
like who's funny I've never wanted to
drown a lady this bad
so just drive so just [ __ ] drown her
out she's a [ __ ] bit like like Joe
said like it's not a gender issue like
how would you feel if we got divorced
you [ __ ] hate my guts some [ __ ]
dick right and then you win a bunch of
money and then we haven't even talked
hate you hate my guts yeah would you
want to drown me yeah absolutely
she wants to drunk people too I think it
makes sense if like let's say they like
he started a business and you know they
were they're husband and wife and for
like ten years
they built I mean he built his business
but she was there like supporting him as
a wife right then she's entitled to it
even though she wasn't a part of the
business cuz there's a lot of help that
she gave right all those things but the
[ __ ] lotto though either one if she
would have wind that love that money she
has no [ __ ] entitlement to that
argument here is also that this was
likely not his very first purchase
ticket so he was probably still buying
lottery tickets when they were married
so some certain extent you scratch that
babe scratch that lotto babe money like
they use like their money to play the
lottery and now he won and they are
still legally married so I think she
should get that money what about the
watch okay she's legally still married
it's his fault I think they took for
[ __ ] ever - finally the
divorce well you didn't do anything for
this ticket I was the stupid one who
bought the ticket by birth three
children okay so you you win you win
eighty million dollars you and Casey
broke up he's a [ __ ] dick he hit his
gut you never want to see him ever again
and then two years later
he finds out you win the library [ __ ]
scenario
dump inna the exact same scenario you
win the lottery she's a [ __ ] she's a
complete [ __ ] [ __ ] tasty thing
that I've been Casey comes in soon and
Sue's you for the money you would hear
this that's a [ __ ] obvious answer you
just paint it in like a piece of [ __ ]
by the way Casey's ban the camera that's
who that's exactly how what happened
yeah they hate each other's guts they
both hate each other no not they're both
the villain in each other's eyes you
don't not always there's some peaceful
divorce it'll be good if they work why
didn't he just give her the money
exactly I had a divorce and I didn't
hate my wife there would be no lawsuit
it's my baby through the lines it's your
son [ __ ] money cuz I want
I have something then uh so if they have
three kids why wouldn't he give her
money that's different
he I would if we had kids well okay they
do all guess I'll give all the money to
the kids while passing it like this
you're assuming that he's a good guy in
his gonna do that that's funny well what
makes you think what makes you think he
asked us she has custody the same thing
that makes you the same thing that makes
you think she's a [ __ ] if she has the
money though right
why would she need to have the money to
raise the kids that's what I don't
understand
also another thing we're knows she's the
one that's handling the expenses they
might be underage this has been a
two-year unfinished divorce so they
probably have today try to work with
that so morally they probably try to
still work things out if I win this
lottery Bay up trophy we'll get back
together you know me oh divorces take a
long time though yeah divorces do take a
long even why would he fight her in
court done so like I also do but with
him I think he's celebrated too early
too if you had some true homeys on the
side and a [ __ ]
your wife's the [ __ ] and she's like um
did you take a helicopter here it's like
no no no
true you should have finalized the
divorce but he probably didn't even
think that she would be entitled to the
money you know he hates her drive more
years after winning the lottery what you
finally go like this [ __ ] up so bad I
would have bought in the shittiest
station wagon ever I were to drove that
lick rickety little guy there I would
have had beer cans fall out of my car as
I get there and I'm like their life
swill it tough sorry
[ __ ] go for it you're like in a suit
but after you sign inside you go [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ] your luxury
yeah I just pictured you in a furry a
suit and then I enjoy riding coach while
I'm in a Gulfstream jet like for the
right I would leave there I would have a
bunch of [ __ ] mostly strong dudes
[ __ ] carrying me out of there with
Cristal
yeah but if you have enough money that
they want to come after I bet you
there's no statute of limitations
they'll just wait even after you signed
a divorce don't [ __ ] come after you
but how do I rub it in her face
you got no bra no way I know the plan
this is the plan you give her the
[ __ ] money cuz she's a [ __ ] right so
you give her the [ __ ] money then
you'd make good with her you store that
money your own half somewhere else in
another country then you divorce now you
have that other happen so I wish you'd
get 3/4 of the [ __ ] money a parts
gangster yeah give back well yeah me I
would have just spent it on everything
Wow spent every last pain were you buy
yeah what yeah what do you things that
she can't sue me for things that are
perishable goods banana bar bunch of
rocks all kinds of yet like she's like
boy you gonna sue me for [ __ ] alright
my [ __ ] quarry he's like yeah
it has bought a fuckload aquarium rocks
we're gonna do that [ __ ]
hey she still takes it and sells it
genius she sold it for exactly what I
paid traveling or experiences that she
can't take yeah it's got to be something
that's spending all that snowmen
perishable hookers spend it all on
snowmen and they're all gonna melt in
their face ha ha thanks I like
terracotta warriors of snowmen and it's
like this is my [ __ ] Legion and
it melts in the summer ball belts and
you're like guess you spent $32 on
terracotta snowman well if you give
money directly to your kids into an
account I don't know if she'll touch
that well she's like completely illegal
I also did my pops I was happy like my
mom was like when a child supporter want
to get more like go to court and get
more child support whatever my dad's
inside I want to give a straight to my
kid that he'll try to do that [ __ ] but
like hey it's not you don't yeah I don't
worry it doesn't work that way I need
just spending more money because like
the money still coming out of his check
at the end of the day but he'll try to
give us you know a 100 to each type of
days like you're still spending more
money pop paper child giving you
directly to the kid yeah there - yeah
I'm so petty I would live under a bridge
so they couldn't get upset from me me
too and then they've come try to take my
cans and all my [ __ ] let you get the
[ __ ] out of here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]